最強的應該是CPU
對 我們看到這一波
最為強勢當然就是在
CPU的部分
因為包括未來
即將要進入這樣高速傳輸的世代
所以從本來的
算力成為這樣子一個
運算的
傳輸的這樣子一個速率更為重心
因為銅線它就是有這樣一個傳輸的極限
那目前如果採用這樣CPU架構
就是在Scale-up的部分
每1.6T的這樣傳輸效率可以
把功耗大幅度的降低
甚至快要來到70%的這個幅度
那這個對於在需要高速傳輸的
這個在機櫃之內
不管是GPU對GPU的連線
或者是跟光纖交換器當中的一個連線
那我覺得目前都是往這個方向去做個發展
所以我們看台廠部分封裝像台積電
訊星還有日月光
那同樣在CPU的封裝當中
會有相關的這個利多
以及在光模組的部分
大力光是這一波
比較入列的新兵
好猛快7000了
對
包括其實它最近又有
蘋果相關的題材
所以幾乎說是雙七的題材
那在上全PoloWay這些等等
也有相關
跟這個輝達
跟彈接電影做一個合作
另外零化音的缺貨
像全新聯誼
IET這些等等
是這一波CPU最新
最開始做一個表態的
好 今天也是
光學類刷一排障聽
那主要我認為應該就是大力光所帶動的對那包括像聯誼光還有金光然後甚至像這個陽明光所以今天表現非常強都創高了耶對 那當然其中有一些是CPO的
那有一些是光學族群被大力光帶起來
我覺得指標然是要看大力光的部分
那現在這個看起來投信一直連買
那股價已經創歷史新高了
那包括接下來蘋果準備要拉貨了
這個在它的這個題材當中
其實我覺得最重要的是在
蘋果後續的一個動能
沒有想到是蘋果的動能
現在是很有趣的一個現象
另外在這個
老的CPU
像潛頂上泉這一排
他們都有各自的
本來的一個利基
包括也有在新高的像聯亞
聯亞今天創歷史新高
真的好猛喔
全新也是快到新高
全新也快到新高了
我覺得這個都是暗示
第一季是讓CPU都漲過一大波
很多CPU可能還是
就是他們都有這種腰骨的體質
那現在其實隨時到2027年
要進入量產元年了
我覺得大家反而可以去注意
第一季其實有飆過一段的CPU
現在可能還在半山
或是還在偏低檔的位階呢
其實我覺得第四季到第一季
馬上做夢的行情又來了
時間過得很快
所以在這個CPU題材當中
我覺得從第一季走過一次
然後第二季修正下來
修正到第三季
他們都是屬於先跌先止跌的
在7月當中
那很多的這個股票
可能都還在相對偏低檔的位置